the written word can be a powerful tool
it has been used to speak truth to power
to allow readers to journey to distant
stars and to explore the forbidden love
triangle between a human girl a vampire
and a werewolf in my personal favorite
book series of all time literature can
be a truly incredible force and like
anything capable of enacting great
change it can be used for good or for
evil in august of 2006 the home of the
leader of a religious group known as the
church of true history was raided by
authorities there they found a variety
of illegal materials but they also
discovered a collection of books one of
the books found was a 450-page hardcover
book entitled chronicle of the 20th
century though it looked like an
ordinary history book concerns
surrounding the religious group and its
leader led the police to analyze its
contents more carefully and if you're
familiar with a certain other anomalous
chronicle you may start feeling nervous
right about now the book's publisher was
listed as interworld press located in
chicago illinois but an investigation
into the publishing company revealed
that the company was never registered in
the united states not only that but the
street it was supposed to be located on
didn't even exist one officer a man
named detective carl jones was assigned
to read through the book and take
thorough notes on anything else unusual
he might find the book consisted largely
of newspaper clippings and short
articles covering significant events
from january of 1900 to december of
1995. as jones flipped through the book
he found that it was well written
thoroughly researched and most
importantly it was largely accurate to
recorded history at least it was until
he reached
from around june 15 1956 onward the
events described began to veer off
course they did not match any version of
history jones was familiar with or
anything he had even heard about it went
from a standard retelling of history to
a sincere account of what appeared to be
an alternative version of history the
strangeness did not end there jones's
colleagues noticed that as his
examination of the book progressed he
began to behave erratically he expressed
confusion and his demeanor took on a
dazed quality he would make statements
about events from the book as if they
were fact and when corrected by one of
the other officers would become
frustrated and overwhelmed he began to
have violent outbursts throwing a cup of
coffee against the wall while arguing
with another man assigned to the case
with him he overturned his desk chair
knocked papers to the floor and even
tore out pieces of his own hair he was
given a psychological evaluation and
found to be struggling with panic
attacks nightmares and paranoia still
jones insisted that he continue to read
through the book as he continued to read
fellow officers noticed that it was not
only his mental state that was affected
his physical state began to change as
well dark circles formed under his eyes
a clear sign of exhaustion a scar
appeared on his cheek where there had
previously been only smooth skin his
knuckles became bloodied though he swore
up and down that he had done nothing to
cause it while sitting at his desk the
officer stationed nearest to jones heard
something small clattered to the floor
he looked up and found that several of
jones's teeth had fallen out for
seemingly no reason finally and most
horrifically jones collapsed to the
floor and became unresponsive he was
rushed to the hospital where he died
within hours an autopsy produced more
questions than answers as his cause to
death was declared radiation poisoning
the police officers on the case
proceeded to interrogate the religious
leader they had apprehended looking for
clues into the mysterious demise of
their fallen colleague he had only owned
the book for two years and that he
imbibed illegal substances to hide from
the truth a week later he slipped into a
coma presumably from withdrawal and died
shortly after the police were at a loss
for explanations how could a book cause
this much damage only one officer among
the group had any inkling of what to do
here and that was because they were
actually an undercover field agent
embedded in the precinct by the scp
foundation the book was soon whisked
away the relevant figures were given
amnestic treatment to forget what they
had seen and the dangerous tome was
logged onto the foundation database
under a new name
scp-592
scp-592 appears to be a perfectly
ordinary book at first glance but it has
been shown to cause delusions paranoia
and a variety of physical changes from
small shifts in appearance to extreme
even deadly wounds understanding that
the book possessed anomalous properties
the foundation set to work trying to
determine how exactly those properties
worked and what triggered them in those
who read its pages it was found that
those who had read only the first half
of the book and stopped would be
completely fine but those who read the
book past the point where the events
began to shift away from recorded
history otherwise known as the point of
divergence would begin to experience the
adverse effects once the subject passed
the point of divergence they would begin
to accept all of the divergent events
described as absolute fact if someone
attempted to speak with them about the
differences between the divergent events
and real recorded history the subject
would become upset and agitated even
subjects who live near the location of
events described in the book form new
vivid memories revolving around personal
experiences related to the event even if
the content of the memories could be
debunked no matter what they would
insist that what they had read in the
book was the truth as they progressed
deeper into the book physical symptoms
would then begin to manifest usually
these begin to appear around 10 years
after the point of divergence and would
worsen as the mental symptoms became
more severe one subject's widow noticed
a scar on his body after his death which
had appeared during the course of his
exposure to the book she was surprised
to see it and said that she had not
noticed it before the foundation became
increasingly concerned with learning how
the book worked what was it that made it
affect people this way its influence was
both physical and mental suggesting a
possible combination of both memetic and
chemical effects dr grayson and the
foundation's chemical forensics team set
about studying the chemical properties
of scp-592
in order to determine if its pages
contained any substances that could
explain its disastrous effects on the
human mind and body small squares of
paper were cut from several pages of the
book cut so small that no more than one
word was contained on each square the
squares were then analyzed and screened
for any anomalies when the results came
back dr grayson and his team were deeply
disappointed the book's pages are made
of standard cellulose and wood printed
with completely ordinary black and
yellow inks there are some unusual
chemicals present in the cyan and
magenta inks used suggesting it was
perhaps made in a location or plane
where chemical quantities differ but
none of them are unknown to science nor
could they be responsible for any of the
damage the book has done to the people
that read it this meant that the book's
effects cannot be explained away by a
new chemical compound or sophisticated
bioweapon something that the chemical
forensics department could study and
develop an antidote for no
scp-592 is much more mysterious and much
more powerful than that
scp-592 is contained in research cell
1611-e in a steel box in the middle of a
frosted glass cubicle in the same
cubicle is a table two computers a
scanner an internal network connection
port and two pairs of goggles which must
be immediately put on by anyone inside
the cubicle these goggles function to
distort the text and images of 592
rendering it impossible for anyone
wearing them to read while wearing them
the first of the two computers is the
analysis machine while the second one
functions as a firewall both computers
have been outfitted with custom software
and hardware in accordance with the
testing protocol and the network port
cannot be used by any device other than
the firewall the computers and the
scanner are kept off when they are not
being used in an experiment and must be
immediately turned off following the
completion of any experimentation the
front and back covers of scp-592 must be
covered in thick black tape at all times
so what is the testing protocol
unscrambled human eyes are no longer
permitted to look at the contents of the
deadly book so the foundation had to
come up with an alternative since
computers aren't capable of experiencing
psychological distress well most of them
aren't
scp-079 might beg to differ of course
the research team decided to find a way
to analyze the book using a computer
system for all testing the book is
scanned one page at a time and then sent
into the analysis machine the machine
has been modified so that it does not
store the original scanned version of
the image and instead converts it
promptly into an analyzed version of the
original content the image is then
promptly erased from the system's ram as
soon as possible this process allows the
research team to study the contents of
scp-592
without exposing themselves or any other
human subjects to the adverse effects of
the book because those under the
influence of the book's effects are
unreliable witnesses this is considered
the only way to ascertain an accurate
neutral understanding of what is written
in these cursed pages there are two
different analysis protocols in place
one for analysis of text and one for
analysis of images because understanding
of the book's specific language could
trigger adverse effects and drive the
remaining members of the research team
to madness the computer analysis of the
text must be as vague as possible while
still providing necessary context the
language used is analytical in tone
describing the subject matter disgust
the tone of the original entry and any
incidents related to the specific
passage for example one piece of text
analysis is as follows the passage is
describing human conflict the human
conflict is of an ideological or
religious nature the passage seems to be
lamenting in tone the passage contains
the numbers 2000 1977
and 16. it is certain 98
that the passage contains a reference to
both scp redacted and scp redacted not
especially descriptive but that's the
point anything more detailed and the
research team not to mention everyone
watching this video at home might be
susceptible to the effects of scp-592
for a clearer picture of how unsettling
the book's contents can get we have to
turn to
well the pictures
scp-592 contains approximately 200
illustrations when a scan page inputted
into the computer includes an image it
is put through several convolutions and
transforms in order to analyze and
summarize its contents in a manner safe
for human consumption
the original image's record is promptly
destroyed it is during this process of
image analysis that things get even
eerier than they already were the images
in the book are not the sort of thing
you'd see in an ordinary history book
the general subject matter of the
pictures is what you might expect people
at various points throughout the 20th
century photographed at historically
significant events or just living their
regular lives during a significant time
period but something about them is wrong
while one researcher was looking through
the computer analysis of the book he
came across an image analysis that made
his blood run cold the page read in
simple text date first april
1963 location unknown bedroom with
western furnishings type full-colored
photograph subject the image contains
two adult persons standing one human
child sitting on a chair or stool and
scp redacted with 100 certainty the
persons in the image should have facial
features with 100 certainty the persons
in the image do not have facial features
now go check out
scp-1025 encyclopedia of common diseases
and scp-1230 a hero is born for more
spell-binding book-based anomalies